-Welcome back.
As you guys know,
we're always striving
to get better here
at "The Tonight Show."
♪ Harder, better,
faster, stronger ♪
[ Laughter and cheers ]
So, before every show,
we put out a suggestion box
for the audience,
just to get some feedback
about what you guys think
of the show,
things you'd like to see us do,
that kind of stuff.
So, tonight, let's look inside
the Audience Suggestion Box.
Here we go.
-♪ Look into the box ♪
♪ The suggestion box ♪
[ Applause ]
-I appreciate these
suggestions, everybody.
This first one
is from @Sherry --
It's not from "at," sorry.
This is from Sherry McFall.
"Hey, Jimmy,
I love 'Yellowstone,'
and I'd love to hear
the theme song done with kazoos.
Can you make that happen?"
Yeah, of course.
Here's the theme from
"Yellowstone" done with kazoos.
Check it out.
[ Kazoos playing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
There you go. That's not bad.
They should use that.
Yeah.
Let's try another one here.
This one's from Dennis Harry.
"Hey, Jimmy. I noticed there are
some buttons on your chair.
I was wondering
what those were for."
Oh, yeah. This is my --
This is my self-driving chair.
-Oh!
-It's -- it's a brand-new thing.
Just came out at CES.
And it's -- I'm one of
the firsts to have it.
-Wow.
-It gets me around the studio
super fast.
The chair just knows
where to go.
It's pretty -- you guys want
to see how it works?
[ Audience cheers ]
Here we go. Here.
You pull up the lever here,
like that.
And then, here we go.
Whoa!
This seat takes off.
Be right back.
[ Wheels rattling ]
Whoo-hoo!
Watch out, watch out,
watch out, watch out!
Whoa!
Coming through!
Oww!
Aah!
Watch out! Whoa!
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no!
[ Screaming ] Oh, God!
Oww!
Whoa-oh-oh-oh!
Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Are you alright?
-What's that?
-Are you alright?
-Perfectly great.
-Did you say CES or CVS?
[ Laughter ]
-We have another
suggestion here.
This one's --
[ Laughter ]
The chair gets me around
the studio.
-It doesn't look like
it's efficient, though.
-Yeah.
Oh, it's fantastic.
-Are you okay?
You seemed like you fell down
a few flights of stairs.
-What? No, no.
No! Was the --
Were the cameras on me?
-Oh, my gosh.
-This is from Tracy Tompkins.
"Jimmy, I love virtual reality.
You should have a VR interview
with someone on the show."
[ Audience murmurs ]
That's a great idea.
We can actually try one
right now.
Tariq, are you down?
-Sure.
-Alright.
Let me just put on
my headset here.
Let's do this, man.
Here we go.
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, my gosh.
How's it going, Tariq?
-Oh, uh, pretty good.
Pretty good.
-Any plans for the weekend?
-Well, yeah, you know, I...
You know, I'mma go see "Avatar"
and also I have to do
some laundry.
-Okay. I'm logging off.
-Copy that.
-Wow. That felt so real.
It felt like I was really
talking to you.
-I know. Yeah. Same here.
-It was wild.
Amazing.
Amazing technology.
Let's try another one.
It's from Erica Dale.
"Hey, Jimmy, I saw
the Property Brothers
were on the show last night.
Can you have
the Property Brothers sing
the Righteous Brothers?"
-Oh!
-Well, yeah, I love
the Righteous Brothers.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
here are the Property Brothers
singing "You've Lost
That Lovin' Feelin'"
by the Righteous Brothers.
Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ You never close your eyes
anymore ♪
♪ When I kiss your lips ♪
-♪ And there's no tenderness ♪
♪ Like before
in your fingertips ♪
-♪ You're trying hard
not to show it ♪
-♪ Baby ♪
-♪ But, baby ♪
♪ Baby, I know it ♪
-♪ You've lost
that lovin' feelin' ♪
♪ Whoa, that lovin' feelin' ♪
♪ You've lost
that lovin' feelin' ♪
♪ Now it's gone, gone, gone ♪
♪ Whoa-oh, whoa-oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
-Come on.
-They were fantastic.
Property Brothers.
-They were delightful.
-I think they missed
their calling.
That's what they
should be doing.
I love that.
-Very well done.
-Here's another suggestion.
This one's from Gwen Noth.
"Hey, Jimmy, you never showed us
the virtual reality footage
from the interview you just did
with Tariq just now."
[ Laughter ]
"Can we see it?"
Oh, yeah.
Well, we couldn't
show it to you earlier,
because our camera systems don't
have the computing capacity
to render the graphics
at such a high frame rate.
But now it's fully rendered.
Do you want to see it?
This is the actual...
[ Audience cheers ]
This is the actual VR footage
from me and Tariq's
interview earlier.
-[Robotic voice] Tariq, hello.
How are you?
-Okay, Jimmy.
-What do your weekend plans?
Okay.
-I'm going to see "Avatar."
Laundry, laundry, laundry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can't get over how real --
it felt so real --
how real it looked.
-It felt like meta, metaverse.
-Amazing. Amazing.
-Yeah.
-We're down to our last
suggestion here.
It's from Nancy Bennion.
It says, "Hey, Jimmy,
help settle a bet.
I think the Wednesday Addams
dance is awesome.
But my friend likes
the creepy robot M3GAN's
dance moves better.
Can you help us figure out,
once and for all,
who's the better dancer?"
I think we can do that.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's time for a dance-off
between Wednesday Addams
and M3GAN the robot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ The Cramps'
"Goo Goo Muck" plays ]
-♪ Yeah, I cruise
through the city ♪
♪ And I roam the streets ♪
♪♪
[ Taylor Swift's "It's Nice
to Have a Friend" plays ]
♪ You better duck ♪
♪ When I show up ♪
♪ The goo goo muck ♪
[ "It's Nice to Have
a Friend" plays ]
-♪ It's nice to have a friend ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Oh-la, oh-la, ayy ♪
♪ Oh-la, oh-la, ayy ♪
♪ Rolling, rolling, roll
with Kid 'N Play now ♪
♪ Rolling, rolling, roll ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Come on, now!
[ Applause continues ]
That's all the time we have
for Audience Suggestion Box.
We're talking with
Chelsea Handler
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.